[موسيقى]
الاعصار هي منطقه هواطي منخفضه تتشكل عاده
في عمق المحيط ونتيجه لهذا الانخفاض فان
جزيئات الهواء تاتي من كل جانب لتعبئه هذا
الفراغ فيحدث تصادم تحاول ان تمتزج فيحدث
الدوران فالاعصار عباره عن رياح عاتيه
مصحوبه بامطار غزيره 65 في اجفان اعصار
اما سئمت ارتحالا ايها ساري اما تعبت من
الاعداء مارحوا يحاورونك بالكبريتي
والناري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فلا تتشكل الاعاصير الا باركان ثلاث الحاض
الانخفاض الضغطي الحركه الحاضن هو المحيط
فلا تتخلق الاعاصير الا في رحم المحيطات
ليه لوجود الرطوبه الجويه العاليه
والحراره المائيه الدائمه فلا تتشكل بل
بحار مثل البحر الاحمر ولا الخلجان مثل
الخليج العربي الانخفاض الضغطي فاذا
انخفضت القيم الضغطيه في مكان ما فانها
تحتاج الى اسعاف من الاماكن المجاوره
الحركه فاذا ترعرع وولد الاعصار في مكان
ما فانه يستنفذ كل الرطوبه المحيطه فيه
ولذلك يحتاج الى ان يتزحزح بحركه حلزونيه
حتى يجدد هذه الرطوبه لتستمر حياته
فالاعصار عباره عن رياح عاتيه مصحوبه
بامطار غزيره تظن قوتك جاء ترهقني ان كنت
ريحا فقد لقيتها اعصارا
[موسيقى]